des monuments historiques en hommage aux
villes martyres ukrainienne de la
seconde guerre mondiale sur lesquels ces
fleurs ont été déposées les signes de
solidarité avec kiev se font discrets
ici à moscou et les paroles contre la
guerre sont prononcés à l'écart de la
foule tout aurait pu se régler
pacifiquement sans faire la guerre pour
que les gens demeurent mahmoudi
d'ukraine est un peuple frère donc je
suis contre
cette opposition ne semble pas massive
parmi les russes mais les sanctions
économiques imposées par les occidentaux
vont elles accroître la défiance envers
vladimir poutine hier le rouble a perdu
30% de sa valeur provoquant devant
certaines banques de longues files
d'attentes pour retirer de l'argent à
moscou aujourd'hui les habitants sont
divisés entre angoisse et lassitude
heureusement les banques ont augmenté le
taux de crédit
moi je n'en ai pas pris mais ma famille
oui ça va augmenter et ça fait très peur
je ne sais pas comment on va vivre
on a l'habitude de vivre et les
sanctions alors pourquoi avoir peur des
conséquences sur la vie quotidienne mais
aussi la vie professionnelle des russes
les liaisons aériennes vers l'europe
sont presque intégralement coupe et ceux
qui travaillent à l'étranger sont
lourdement impacté
l'activité a souffert bien sûr d'abord à
cause du coc vide et maintenant à cause
des sanctions et des pays qui ne livre
plus de visas
eh bien on fera avec on peut toujours se
réorienter vers autre chose
pour les russes ce ne sont que les
premiers effets des multiples sanctions
prises contre leur pays et face à moscou
la réponse